other news here at six the palms is back
yeah that's right property leaders
announcing today it will reopen under
new ownership opening date april 27th
the hotel casino has been closed for
about two years now but today eight news
now got a look inside christian costas
joins us now from the palms and kristen
you got to see firsthand what guests can
expect when they open their doors at the
end of the month right
that's right just so much excitement as
this las vegas staple very soon will be
shining again now let me tell you we are
right now in the valley portion of the
property and as you can see a lot of
work still needs to be done ahead of
that opening for example some of the
signage around the property now keep in
mind there was a big big renovation
before the shutdown happened and now the
new ownership hopes that the community
will embrace them
thanks for choosing the palms a new
chapter is about to begin for palms
casino resort construction crews are up
against the clock to make everything
ready for the launch on april 27th this
time under new owners we're going to
celebrate
in the culture of our we are the first
native american owned and operated
resort in las vegas the san manuel
gaming and hospitality authority
purchased the 766 room property off
flamingo and valley view boulevard from
station's casinos last year in 2020 the
pandemics shut down operations after
going through a 600 million dollar
renovation which general manager cynthia
kaiser hopes will help attract the
crowds we are completely redoing our
sportsbook it's going to be a really
premium viewing experience the return of
scotch 80 prime and mabel's barbecue
also on the list of dining and
entertainment and the properties movie
theater is getting a new stadium seating
and technology johnny brendan hired
local graffiti artists to redo
all of the theater quarters and then
another artist to redo the floors the
palms will open right as las vegas
welcomes the nfl draft kaiser says the
palms is beefing up staff hiring about
100 new employees and plans to create a
neighborhood vibe inside the resort are
on track thanks to the former staff now
back on duty we've had over we believe
almost 50 percent of our team are going
to be returning palms employees and we
are just
really really excited about that
all right back out here live kaiser
murphy also telling me that the very
first reservation happened this morning
so exciting stuff there also the ghost
bar expected to open shortly after the
property does and get this guys the
garage parking i'm told
will be free christian casa is live
local now